before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
look this episode's so weird i can't
even think of a way to kick this off
with a joke
should have gotten a frog
[Music]
and we have arrived at what i have gone
on record before as being my favorite
episode of series 11 and one of my
favorite episodes of jody whitaker's
time as the doctor
it takes you
away
now
this is one that i actually
i don't really know what the i i do
think that i think more highly of this
than most people do i don't think it's
excessively maligned except for one
specific aspect that i know people have
have brought up to me repeatedly before
if you know the episode and if you've
been around in my comments you know what
it is
we'll get to it
but for the most part i love this
episode i loved it first time i saw it
and honestly i still like it a lot now
it's
weird
and it's weird in a really unique and
inventive way i think i even said at the
time that it reminds me of like the
1960s and 70s style sci-fi the sci-fi of
the mind it reminds me of stuff like a
wrinkle in time and that sort of
weirdness that feels like it's partially
a head trip but also partially
uh sci-fi it has influences of things
that feel more like traditional sci-fi
but also just
weirdness because
there's no reason that the universe
wouldn't produce something this weird
the universe is huge yeah some stuff's
gonna be really freaking weird and
i love that vibe
and this thing has it
in spades
across the board like pretty much as
soon as they even get to the house like
there's a great atmosphere it's shot
very ominously and there's a lot of
harsh angles like the fact that the
windows in that house are are these
triangles it's already or at least as
someone from america i don't know if
that actual kind of design is something
that's standard for norway where it's
set but like for someone who's used to
square or circular
windows seeing these really harsh
triangles
yeah i know it's a little off-putting
and it leans into that and then the
stuff with the mirror it's like wait a
minute what is going on then they go
through that and it's yeah it's a cave
system and it's not that visually
exciting but
it's all so weird they don't know where
they are they don't know what's going on
they run into this guy who they don't
know if they can trust i like ribbons as
well
and i like
that he just
takes everything for granted they even
ask him how did you even get here
is that true who knows maybe he's lying
maybe he's literally spent his entire
life here maybe he's only like
a few hours old we don't know how long
this thing's been going on but for as
far as he's concerned always been here
doesn't make traditional sense no but it
shouldn't and then the moths like here's
the like this should give you an idea of
how much i like this episode something
like the moths which are presented as
basically like reverse moths where they
won't eat your clothes but they'll eat
your your flesh
that's the kind of thing that in
i'm not gonna say any other episode but
in a fair number of other episodes i
would have scoffed out i'm like that's
kind of dumb
but you know what you couch it in an
episode with this much weirdness going
on and this general vibe of like wait
what
and
i'll roll with it
and that's kind of the thing some ideas
feel
inherently silly but honestly most ideas
if you can couch them in a context where
they fit
can work and i feel like
this is a story and a vibe and an
episode
where big freaking moths that eat skin
instead of clothes actually work
so
there you go
um i part of me i think i'm reading too
much into this
i i mentioned something like a wrinkle
in time the other vibe i get at least
for this kind of weirdness is uh
something kind of douglas adamsy
especially towards the end with like the
fact that an entire universe presents
itself as a frog
that feels very douglas adams why a frog
why not a frog
is there any reason it should be
anything other than a frog no k then
it's a frog and that feels very douglas
adams it doesn't have his sense of humor
but it does seem to have his approach to
absurdity which is
sometimes you explain the weirdness and
sometimes you go
okay why not and the reason i bring that
up is because i'm probably reading too
much into this but the fact that it
opens in norway and they bring attention
to what graham uh identifies as a fjord
ah nice field
that is a field
and knowing that fjords kind of feature
a bit in hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy because it was the part of norway
that slady barthas worked on and was
really proud of and won an award for
doing fjords i don't know i hope that
was a that was a subtle little uh
douglas adams reference
i don't know if it was i'm going to
choose to believe it was regardless of
the reality
but i've just kind of been talking
vibe and like there you go i love
the vibe of this thing absolutely adore
it still even now
love it
so
what about the rest of it
well i think the character work in here
is actually pretty good it's debatable
whether or not some of the stuff that's
been done here should have been
kind of more carried over across more of
the episodes i think graham is kind of
the big question there i do feel that
within the confines of this episode his
just conflict in his being torn up about
encountering what as far as he is
concerned is grace
that what that does to him and how hard
that is for him to be around
don't do this to me
i think bradley walsh sells that really
well this
this sadness this missing her and the
pull and the allure of that
um i think there's an argument to be
made that
they kind of let the impact of grace
drift off after
oh roundabout rosa was the last time i
remember the mentions of her really
standing out to me there were there were
probably a few others since then
but like the fact that they haven't
stuck in my head
that's
kind of telling
but at the same time i do feel that this
does work
uh within those confines and again um
yaz and her interactions with hana um
again sort of feel like leaning on the
idea that she is
calling you as a people person feels
like an overstatement but she's used to
just sort of getting people comfortable
with her trying to put them at ease um i
like how awkward ryan is around her and
it kind of brings in his baggage about
his own father in a way that doesn't
feel expositional it and it shouldn't be
done as exposition at this point we know
some of the deal with his father at this
point but it does uh you know feel
appropriate to the situation given his
baggage
out of the four of them he's going to be
the one who's going to suggest the
possibility maybe her dad just ran off
and it also makes sense for hannah to
resent him
for that i really like um the doctor you
know writing out a message to
uh ryan and claiming here i just drew
you a map so that she could relay
information uh to him without hana who
is uh blind for all intents and purposes
she does say she can kind of see light
if she's close to it but for all
practical purposes of the narrative she
is blind and you know that's a way to
relay the information but i also like
that anna is not dumb
she knows what it sounds like when
someone writes words
she knows that it's not a map
and i i think that
that she's well done
i don't love the name of this other uh
universe thing being the soluti like
again chibnall these names
man
your alien being names
suck
they really do but
i just kind of like again the weirdness
of this idea of
this universe that
is lonely
basically like it just wants to not be
alone
but the problem is by the nature of its
existence it
cancels things out when brought in
contact with our universe
it wants to have someone else there
but doing so
starts to crumble reality there's a
melancholy and a sadness to that that i
also think feeds into the fact that it
brings people on board
by presenting them with a loved one that
they've lost i think that this thing
while it may not have lost a level in
the same way this thing feels alone in
the way that people like
graham and eric
feel alone and is calling out to them
offering a solution to their loneliness
in order to satisfy its own need to fill
that void i
really enjoy all that there's a ton of
like really interesting tiny moments
just in terms of the the visual
presentation of things as well but also
there's like some cool little story um
touches as well i kind of like the fact
that the dead people in this other
universe
they know they're dead they're not
trying to pretend otherwise they know
this makes no sense but they're not
trying to appeal to reason they're
trying to appeal to emotion
they don't have to make sense they just
have to be appealing enough
to make people stay
there's a few really good lines uh
ribbons gets one information is sadly so
expensive
you don't have such credit and there's
another line later on i think it was
from yaz when you put it like that it
sounds like a trap
and those are lines that are
accomplishing pretty basic stuff you
know ribbons laying out you're gonna
have to give me something to get what
you want from me and you know them
saying i think we made a mistake coming
here it's you know it's a trap but
they're just good lines used to relay
those things
i like that the doctor gets the solution
to let eric go because she basically
sells herself as a better companion to
this entity than these people will ever
be
i like that the doctor seems to convey a
sense of genuine
regret at leaving this thing alone she
does seem to really feel bad about it
and part of me wonders if the universe
wasn't going to completely come apart
from her staying there
would she have stayed maybe not forever
but i think part of her definitely
wanted to and that comes across in the
performance so this is another instance
where i feel like jodie whittaker not
only gives some really good uh
presentation in terms of how she handles
the doctor what pulls the doctor in what
intrigues the doctor what latches into
her brain and hits her in the two hearts
but also like it's just better material
than she's often given this is not
expositional stuff this is emotional
storytelling these are emotional moments
and she does them real well
but i set aside something at the start
so
we need to talk about
eric
eric
is the father
the father who in an effort to have more
time with his dead wife
left his child
alone
for days
in a house
and not only left her there
but set up this sound system to create
scary noises outside and frighten her
out of the idea of leaving i'm gonna hit
him no you're not
i am
now
i've seen people complain that the
episode doesn't properly grapple with
what he did and i've had multiple people
now
um
try and throw it in my face specifically
the fact that i am a self-avowed lover
of this episode but i deeply hate
the idiot's lantern
which has a father character
who is
an absolutely atrocious human being is
expelled from the house but then gets
reached out to almost immediately by the
sun at the encouragement of rose and
it's treated like a good thing and i
deeply loathe
that aspect of that episode and it's an
episode i don't like anyway but that is
what makes it my single most hated
episode of doctor who i've ever seen i
find that legitimately dangerous
and while i will make no excuses for
eric
these are not equivocal
so if you want to know why i'm mad
about the idiot's lantern but i'm not
mad at this
it's because idiot's lantern frames
reaching out and keeping contact with a
demonstrably toxic cruel person is a
good thing
it frames rose's advice
for this young boy to immediately reach
out not even be like reach out to him in
a week see how he's doing like no he
literally is walking down the street
from just being expelled from the house
rightfully so and she says go to him
tommy go after him
what for
he's your dad no that
is
dangerous
that is not what is presented here
nobody
is saying to hana or anybody else
you should have forgive him
now it is correct to say that it doesn't
really properly grapple with how bad it
was what he did about the only person
who really properly seems to have a good
vibe on that is ryan and even ryan by
the end isn't really talking about it
anymore
so i will grant
that this is a problem
and it is
under examined
however
eric
while
deeply selfish
i know i stayed away from honor too long
but i kept thinking what if i go and i
can't come back
and i mean really selfish
is not actively cruel
the father and idiot's lantern was
actively cruel
and directly harmful
eric is selfish and negligent neither of
which are good things
but between that and the framing of the
idiot's lantern that reaching out to a
person like that is a good thing like
actively encouraging an abuse victim to
mend the bridge with their abuser no no
no no that is not equivocal to the
mistakes of this episode this episode
does make mistakes now i'm done
comparing to the idiots lantern because
i don't just want to feel like i'm
defending this because it's not as bad
as that
because it isn't but also
yeah this doesn't really properly
grapple with this
it is brought to his attention
and he makes his excuses
nobody defends what he does
which is good
because it's pretty indefensible
but it also seems like nobody's really
going to hold into account to that
hana is just too happy to see him
and while he says you know they're going
to move back to the city like well
that's good she won't be stuck in a
freaking cabin with no access to help
anymore so that's a good thing
but it becomes one of those things where
i think the main thing honestly this
probably could have been
largely at least to my satisfaction
address with just a tiny tweak
have him not be gone for as long
still have him like establish to her the
um you know the the sounds outside and
that's all fake and like but he he set
that up and like started talking about
oh there's a thing out there like weeks
ago
but he's only been gone like
two days
or even beyond that
if you really want to go light on it
because this episode doesn't seem to
want to grapple with this if you're not
prepared to grapple with this just have
it be that time doesn't work the same
just have them get there and he goes
wait it's been how long i thought i've
only been here for like five hours
and if you still want to hold his feet
to the fire you could have someone like
yes come on like you left your daughter
alone for five hours
and you know you could still hold it to
it but it would be less egregious i and
again this is not to say that it any of
it's okay
but at this point having him gone for
like four days or whatever it is it's
the fact that it's not grappled with is
distracting to the point that it it
takes away from
all the other stuff that this episode
does that i really really really love
and while i still feel that all that
stuff holds up
even with this issue i will absolutely
come to the fact that it is an issue but
i don't think it's that difficult to
tweak you gotta tweak the timeline to
make it so that it's not so egregious
that the fact that it goes
largely unaddressed doesn't become as
big an issue because as it currently
stands yeah no it is an issue but i
think the fact that it would be fixable
with a minor tweaking as opposed to i
know i said it was done comparing it but
i'll do it one more time as opposed to
say the idiot's lantern where you have
to completely chuck the idea of this boy
reaching out to his abusive freaking
father
ah
so
while i am not going to defend eric as a
character good grief no
i don't
see the same potential for damage in
what's presented here versus what
happened there and as a result i'm not
saying i'm forgiving of this aspect but
it doesn't ruin what i love and what i
love about this episode
i still love even on a re-watch
it takes you away
you've seen it lately you re-watched it
what'd you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it patreon's
what pays the bills enables me to do
this as my job any amount you can help
me out there is greatly appreciated but
even if you can't like share subscribe
hit the bell i don't tell people to do
that but go ahead hit the bell if you
feel like it but even if you don't don't
worry about it because what's important
and what i want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin luthfalla turak oliver b melinda
walters imudelkey the oath the boy tt
for nobulax the poodle zach paul idoln
tracy scrappet vincent paul bartolucci
angry casper toku b.l huvian adam rdl
taylor shane ross shaylee gourley and
brendan larose you want to hear me
mispronounce your name check out rewards
on the patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]
um
[Music]